hallo herzlich willkommen sally fest
[Musik]
szabados geldes wir sind gerade hier in
istanbul direkt auf bosporus ziehen so
wie ihr seht ihr die bosporusbrücke und
es ist gerade atemberaubend schön das
wetter ist war es ist ein leichter wind
also wirklich wunderschön am liebsten
würde ich den moment einfrieren und für
immer hierbleiben mit dem ehrenteller
natürlich sagt auch in bestimmten grund
dass wir gerade in istanbul sind
denn wie in istanbul oder überhaupt in
der türkei gibt es wirklich ganz viele
deutsche marken die man kennt jedes
zweite dritte auto kommt aus deutschland
es gibt küchengeräte hier und die
menschen hier sind wirklich stolz drauf
dann deutsche produkte und deutsche
geräte benutzen zu dürfen weil sie sagen
wenn es aus deutschland kommt da muss
eine top qualität haben
andererseits kann man aber wirklich an
einer hand abzählen wie viele türkische
marken es gibt die wirklich weltweit
bekannt sind und renommiert sind und das
ist wirklich super schade aber eine
türkische marke kind glaube ich jeder
von euch und das ist die marke bosch
erwarte als ich meinem papa erzählt habe
dass wir mit pascha brachte
zusammenarbeiten dass die uns beliefern
und sogar eigene produkte für uns
herstellen da wahre echte tränen gerührt
und das bin ich auch ich bin echt mega
stolz drauf das sagen zu dürfen
deswegen wollte ich euch mit in die
türkei nehmen hier nach istanbul
denn hier hat alles mit pascha war vor
vielen vielen jahren angefangen aber
papa brachte ist nicht einfach nur eine
türkische marke sie beliefern wirklich
über 160 länder der welt überall kennt
man die gläser über all das geschehe und
vor allem würde ich echt wetten dass in
jedem haushalt auch für euch zu hause
mindestens ein glas von paszek steht
denn sie machen nicht nur eigenen lebens
sondern produzieren auch für viele viele
weitere marken der welt und ich finde
ziehe ich die produktvielfalt von
pascher macht zu zeigen angefangen
natürlich beim ganz traditionellen
teglas welches ihr auch bei uns im shop
bekommt und natürlich auch kennt das
verlies und das morath glas aber pass
erwachte hat auch produkte die zum
beispiel aus borosilikatglas stellt
werden wie ofen formen oder auch meinen
eigenen messbecher und gerade jetzt zu
corinna zeiten muss ich auch so zu sagen
aber wir haben beim dreh wirkt sich
extrem darauf aufgepasst dass wir
wirklich immer mundschutz tragen den
nasen mundschutz und nur für kamera
zwecke die maske abnehmen
aber in der türkei muss ich auch sagen
dass die auflagen und die regelungen
wirklich ganz ganz streng sind selbst in
der öffentlichkeit draußen auf der
straße überall muss maske getragen
werden
deswegen wäre es wirklich nicht auf die
leichte schulter genommen sondern gehen
sehr verantwortungsbewusst damit um
ich würde sagen ich genieße es hier noch
meinen teil muss brust und dann nehme
ich euch mit in die welt erwarte
[Musik]
ok ich muss euch leider vorwarnen ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass es so schön ist
also gehen wir einfach nicht wahr es
jetzt schon es wird eskaliert und es
habe ich hier mein geld drin nein nation
dem autoverkehr und warum aber der
gegner sein und nehme ich mir
ich sehe jetzt schon es ist einfach mehr
als notar
[Musik]
ich nehme euch jetzt einfach mit also
wir machen jetzt einfach so eine
komplette top tour weil ich glaube ich
kann kein regal hieraus lassen
[Musik]
die passen so perfekt in meinem
wohnzimmer
wenn es ein moratorium fällig athen
zeigt werkzeug mal diese katzen
collection oder auf das hier und zwar
ist ein berühmter maler der künstler in
der türkei ist ad hoc demirel und er hat
diese ganzen serie hier design das
kasachische arbeitet auch mit
verschiedenen künstlern die machen
eigene kollektionen und ich finde es
echt schön vor allem weil dann alles so
individuell wird richtig tolles design
könnt ihr euch gut
[Musik]
das komplette glas was eben geht am pott
ist das heißt aus kurve silikat glas das
ist hitzebeständig ist eure fest und es
ist einfach so dass stabil was man
bekommt was es eben an glas ist und
daraus wird zum beispiel auch unsere
messbecher hergestellt da ist auch aus
borosilikatglas damit wenn ihr auch
heiße flüssigkeiten einfüllt eine suppe
püriert oder das ganze sogar erwerben
dem backofen eben das glas nicht
zerspringt also ist ein ganz spezielles
verfahren sind auch ganz spezielle
materialien die eben in dem glas benutzt
werden ganz spezielle rohstoffe und das
ist so die botschaft serie und da gibt
es einfach verschiedene modelle
wir hatten uns auch für die hier
entschieden für den online-shop und für
den shop in mannheim
weil ich die einfach megaschön fans denn
die meisten haben wir immer runde
auflaufform oder so eckige die aber
nicht ganz wirklich sind und da ist
pascha brachte so der einzige hersteller
der diese 90 grad winkel hinbekommt
richtig schöne ecken also darum tiramisu
oder braunes oder andere tolle rezepte
mega cool und jetzt erfahren wir sind
die einzigen in deutschland verkaufen
[Musik]
plötzlich interessiert mich geschichte
doch ich bin dein vater mega diesen
richtig schön aber was
was bedeutet das eigentlich genau also
wir haben unsere flaschen drin hat das
sagen dass fragen uns hat sich auch
viele zuschauer und zwar hat es eine
lange geschichte vor jahrtausenden war
es nämlich so dass wenn menschen mit
einem blauen auge auf die welt kamen
dachte man wenn zum beispiel diese
menschen zu jemandem sagt over schöne
haare dass dann der blick dieser blauen
augen einfach was böses macht das heißt
ich sag dir das schöne haare und dann
fallen die alle haare aus und da hatte
man einfach angst davor das heißt alle
menschen mit blauen augen vor
jahrtausenden waren praktisch die hatten
dieses böse auge und um sich davor zu
schützen hat man eben das blaue auge
gemacht und es kennt man auch so auch
heute wird es noch so gemacht dass wenn
ein baby auf die welt kommt oder an
autos sich kauft oder ein haus baut dann
ist es einfach so dass man ein blaues
auge dran hängt und dieses blaue augen
schützt sich dann vor allem blöd bösen
blicken
man sagt hier aus
genau macht genau gesagt man so und
deswegen das blaue auge und daher ist es
eben auch mehr
und dann sagt man eben noch dazu macht
das heißt gott wollte es so deswegen ist
es so und deswegen wenn ich jetzt so
sara sagt sarah das so schöne haare
waschen dann hätte ich dir nach auge
dran und dann hätte ich den augen müssen
und dann und dann schützt sie vor dem
wissen ja jetzt habt ihr mal die ganzen
eindrücke hier gesehen also ich selbst
bin mega überwältigt ich würde jetzt
aber mal sagen wir gehen jetzt ins
hauptquartier von patsch erwartet
ich nehme euch mal mit aber dafür müssen
noch einmal kurz durch istanbul durch
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt hier ein paar schwarze
gebäude angekommen und natürlich
herrschen hier ganz große
sicherheitsmaßnahmen dh am eingang muss
direkt jeder seine taschen abgeben
es gibt eine personenkontrolle und weil
eben momentan noch pandemie zeiten sind
wird auch gleich fieber gemessen um
einfach sicherzustellen dass jeder der
hier ankommt zum einen gesund ist und
keine gefährlichen gegenstände mit sich
trägt
er war direkt am eingang werden dann
auch noch die personendaten erfasst und
man bekommt einen besucherausweis und
darf dann das gebäude betreten
wir sind die zehn wörter also im büro
gebäude von tasche machte und ich muss
sagen wir als team sind mega beeindruckt
weil es einfach so ein modernes gebäude
ist richtig schön und groß und
vielleicht ganz kurz zum hintergrund die
marke tasche macht er gehört zu schicken
und schicke jump ist einer der grössten
glaswaren hersteller der welt und ich
finde da kann man schon ein bisschen
stolz drauf sein vor allem weil er
wirklich auch jeder von euch mindestens
ein glas zu hause von pascher warte hat
jetzt würde ich sagen gehen wir einen
showroom schauen uns ja alles mal an und
ich lasse mir einfach mal erklären was
sind hier alles passiert
im showroom treffe ich jetzt die
menschen die hinter den einzelnen
produktbereichen stehen zum beispiel ist
produkt leiterin im bereich trends und
neuheiten
[Musik]
in der mitte sieht man immer so die
aktuellsten trends also des netzbetriebs
für 2020 die trends für 2021 sind auch
schon auf dem weg und da kommt eben
immer drauf an da kommen neue designs
zum beispiel und grad bei geschirr
gläsern ist natürlich wichtig dass die
farben lebensmittelecht sind und hier
ist wir jetzt einfach so gemacht dass
die farbe immer schon außen aufgedrückt
werden das heißt die lebensmittel kommen
auch gar nicht direkt mit der farbe in
kontakt
[Musik]
er ist seit über 20 jahren im verkauf
zuständig und ist unser direkter
ansprechpartner rabatte und mittlerweile
muss ich auch echt sagen richtig unserer
einzigen ortes erklären sie haben hat
die mord serie also was ich auch schon
erklärt habe aus borosilikatglas sehr
hitzebeständig temperaturbeständig und
eben auch säure fest und das nennt diese
tollen auflaufform und die offenen
formen und hier haben wir einen stick
serie und dies ganz besonders weil hier
eine beschichtung mit drin ist und
daneben auch nichts mehr am glas haftet
das ganze ist natürlich eine
antihaftbeschichtung die aber eben
gesundheitlich wirklich unbedenklich ist
selbst wenn ihr mit einem messer
schneidet und die beschichtung zeit
kraft und zerstört ist es eben nicht
gesundheitsschädlich und was es an
backeigenschaften verbessert ist
folgendes glas ist ja wirklich super
glatt und wenn ihr zum beispiel einen
biscuit im glas packt dann rutscht der
eigentlich am rand immer wieder runter
kann gar nicht hoch klettern und was man
hier eben hat diese beschichtung dies so
leicht angeraut das heißt da kann der
teig einfach schön am rand hochklettern
rutscht nicht runter löst sich aber nach
dem backen perfekt wieder ab und
deswegen hat man hier eben diese
beschichtung mit reingepackt und ich
werde es auf jeden fall daheim austesten
und wenn es cool ist an dem was direkt
mit auch bei uns also für mich ist es
jetzt auch so eine kleine abenteuer
reise denn ich habe in deutschland
natürlich auch nicht alles an produkten
gesehen selbst auf der ambiente nicht
und jetzt kann ich mich hier so ein
bisschen entfalten und entdecken und
alles was ich cool finden wir dann
einfach direkt mit auf das ist ja also
gehört zeigt in der mitte genau er ist
natürlich mit der gleichen pro portion
klar ist dass es langsam so dass du die
zeit hast was der teig in einem drin
sich auch noch
ich probiere die auf jeden fall auswahl
finde ich die optisch voll stellen so
weise
ich habe gerade so mein auge hier so
drüber
und sehe diese rührschüssel und was sag
ich immer sagen man hätte auch eine
größere risse zu sehen können weil wir
beim rühren immer alles raus springt
über glück ist nichts mehr
ich denke also ist leiterin im bereich
marketing und erklärt mir hier gerade
eine der beiden großen innovationen in
diesem jahr und zwar ist hier die
kollektion die er bei kollektion wird zu
100 prozent aus recyceltem glas gewonnen
und hergestellt und da war einfach die
schwierigkeit immer bisher darin bei der
glasproduktion werden maximal fünf
altglas benutzt um eben neues glas
herzustellen
und hier hat man einfach 100 prozent
altglas branche sagt alles was wir auf
der welt hinterlassen
darüber sollte man sich eben viel
gedanken machen und deswegen nehmen sie
das komplette altglas schmerzt uns 1 und
haben jetzt hier einfach eine schöne
produktionsserie gemacht und nicht nur
das glas ist 100 prozent recycelt
sondern auch die verpackung also da
stimmt einfach wirklich die komplette
geschichte und man hat hier ein produkt
was zu 100 prozent nachhaltig ist
parken ist für den internationalen markt
zuständig und erklärt mich hier gerade
die zweite große innovation in diesem
jahr
innovation bedeutet hier auch dass man
spontan auf geschehen zu reagiert und
pasha branche sagt sich wir sind so ein
tolles weltunternehmen vorreiter und
natürlich auch vorbild und deswegen
nehmen sie die pandemie natürlich auch
sehr ernst das bedeutet sie haben hierzu
eine innovation die nennt sich wie block
und oftmals werden ja krankheiten über
den kontakt vieler menschen übertragen
man fast ein gegenstand an
da setzten sich während darauf ab dann
kommt ein anderer mensch nimmt es in die
hand und dann ist eben dieser mensch
direkt angesteckt und hier ist eine
besondere beschichtung drauf auf den
gläsern so dass einfach der hand und
hautkontakt eben die viren nicht mehr
überträgt das heißt hier sind
antibakterielle und antivirale
beschichtung drauf und da sind sie
wirklich vorreiter werden es jetzt
zuerst mal in der türkei austesten jetzt
in der testphase und danach geht das
ganze eben auch in die ganze welt
[Applaus]
thomas selbst im vessertal gläser werden
hier hergestellt wie fällen gehe ich
jetzt noch gemeinsam alle produkte durch
die ich in meinem online shop und auch
stationär in mannheim aufnehmen möchte
wir wollen auf jeden fall espresso
gläser
denn ich finde es einfach wunderschön
schaut mal wenn du mal jetzt ein
espresso tassen halt immer aus porzellan
und ich finde ich echt langweilig
gesunde also die finde ich schön aber
ich bin ein mega fan auch von der hier
die so schöne rundlich geformt er war
avastin für die weil wir fangen schon
ursprünglich war da dann haben wir
gesagt wir wollen so eine klar und ich
finde dass es die perfekte geschenk
[Musik]
dafür ist euch mitnehmen und wir dürfen
jetzt sehen wie glas entsteht wir sind
das erste filmteam was die heiligen
hallen von pascher brachte sehen darf
also kommt mit und entdeckt mit mir wie
glas entsteht
[Musik]
wenn der produktion sind alle
sicherheitskleidung an
und dann gibt es hier steht überall dass
man hier nicht filmen und fotografieren
wir haben aber wir sind das erste kamera
macht denn die heiligen hallen darf und
die produktion sich anschauen und dann
nehme ich euch jetzt mit und zeigt euch
wie klaas im allgemeinen hergestellt
wird und vor allem die vor uns liegt
das besondere daran
je nachdem was für ein glas man
natürlich herstellen möchte sind
natürlich die zutaten andere der
hauptbestandteil ist aber quarzsand das
läge hier im hintergrund quandt sieht so
aus im rohen zustand und der wird dann
gemischt mit nato und karbonat und auch
mit bisschen altem glas heißt wir doch
viel glas recycelt
[Musik]
hier sieht man jetzt auch das ganze glas
was eben kaputt gegangen ist und als
recyclingmaterial zurückkommt da gibt
auch ganz viele unterschiede zum einen
gips glas was eben für trinkgläser
benutzt wird und dann gibt es auch noch
das gestempelte glas also dass
borosilikatglas und da sieht man auch
den unterschied des buches city card
glas das sieht man auch die ganzen ofen
formen die ganzen figuren und modelle
denn das glas geht einfach nicht so
schnell kaputt das heißt wirklich kannst
du mich vorwarnen
ich wollte damit wollten sie schon immer
mal in meinem leben machen
hast du auch mal gemacht scherben
bringen glück markus ja einfach mal
ausrasten einmal in meinem leben
ok ich erst einmal komplett aus ich
hab's zerstört murat kommen jetzt gehen
wir rein schauen uns an wie die
rohstoffe vermischt werden und wie aus
diesem ganzen material hier klagt
entsteht ist noch gut
[Musik]
ja warte noch wartet kurz valley passt
hier sitzt eben prinzipien der backstube
hier entstehen rezepte je nachdem
welches glas sich herstellen möchte
werden eben auch verschiedene zutaten
zusammen gemischt das kann man es
vergleichen wie beim quali denn machen
oder beim kuchenbacken und ihr seht hier
die einzelnen seelos da sind die
rohstoffe drin die werden von außen mit
lkws angeliefert werden dann per
luftdruck nach oben gepumpt landen hier
in silos und hier kommen die einzelnen
zutaten dann zusammen werden hier unten
vermischten im mixer und gehen dann über
förderbänder nach drüben in die schmelz
schale
hier seht ihr jetzt die förderbänder
über die förderbänder gelangen die backe
stoffe also die backmischung gelangt
dann nach oben in die schweiz schale
aber das kann ich dem rat viel besser
weil ich jetzt mal ohne spaß ich habe
das früher ich habe ihn früher nur diese
rollen repariert ich weiß so ganz die
musste mit der stange immer anheben
die bänder habe ich ausgetauscht und ich
muss ehrlich sagen ich sitz extrem
sauber aus also es ist eine krasse
staubentwicklung was sie nachher
passiert und und das ist zum beispiel
sollen so in sicherheit sei wenn hier
irgendwas sein sollte wenn hier
irgendjemand ist um was und zieht an
diesem seit bleibt die ganze anlage
komplett stehen also komm wir schalten
jetzt die maschinen aber schalten um an
[Musik]
ob die halt stopp stopp stopp
bevor es allerdings zum schnellsten geht
der rohstoffe möchte ich euch zeigen das
ist ein ganz wichtigen zwischenschritt
gibt und den wird euch aber mein
vorgesetzter herr ostern erklären
er ist schon darf ich die 14 reinstecken
heute haben sie alles gemäß ja alle
rohstoffe sind vermischt alles lag ich
las den mich schon mal lauten ja alles
klar
ich hätte jetzt sind wir an einer stelle
um gelungen ist war früher mein beruf
und zwar als wahnsinnig jahren endlich
sterben hab ihn pls bedient es nennt
sich bls als eine abkürzung für
prozessleitsysteme alles was ihr
passiert alles was hier gemischt wird
und den ganzen die ganzen misch
vorgänger sehen wir hier visualisiert
wie ist die rezeptur wie lang wird
gemixt wie ist die luftfeuchte wie ist
die home and run genau
und hier sehen ist selbst ein kleines
motörchen ihren störung bekommt sofort
angezeigt und weiß dann sofort und
schickt dann die monteure aus kasan
motor 4 an der steuerung 7 im mischer
drei bitte ist kaputtgegangen bitte
bitte bitte reparieren ja auf jeden fall
wie gesagt ist es ganz cool dann nämlich
sind zu haben ist auch die
arbeitssicherheit man weiß wo man
arbeitet und das machen wir ganz ruhig
also ich könnte mich ich finde hier noch
zwei pommes bitte eine pizza und eine
kirche in brötchen angeschaut
[Musik]
prof
uns eine typische schmelzer ein
schnellsten
hier wird jetzt nicht mehr benutzt aber
sie wurden früher 75 tonnen glas
geschmolzen also rohstoffe des stolzen
preises klar feuer drin und im trab
hielt ihr aussehen weil dein komplette
boden
dahinten seht ihr auch die löcher kam
bereits rund 1500 grad
ich will mir nicht vorstellen wir ein
bisschen drin vor allem wichtig russell
jobs mit vor allem menschen die hier
arbeiten
die haben sich richtig richtig fahrt kam
und ich schwitze hier oben an der spitze
wie die schweizer halten muss
ja
[Musik]
ich erkläre ich kurz am beispiel von
borosilikatglas wie glas entsteht
der name setzt sich aus den komponenten
mit dem größten anteilen zusammen
siliziumdioxid also quarzsand und
portrait oxid also bohr und sauerstoff
dazu kommen dann noch glänzende metalle
wie zum beispiel beryllium magnesium
oder calcium und wenn man dann noch
andere stoffe beifügt kann man die härte
farbe und die glas kommission
beeinflussen aber wieso stellt man
überhaupt borosilikatglas herr buri
silikat ist aufgrund des borg gehalts
besonders beständig gegen säure
chemikalien und pharmazeutische produkte
außerdem springt das glas nicht bei
extrem plötzliche wärme oder auch kälte
und deswegen ist es ideal für die küche
und eben auch zum backen und kochen
geeignet die inhaltsstoffe werden
vermischt und bei circa 1600 grad
celsius geschmolzen
das glas fließt durch mehrere kanäle und
wird dabei auf 1200 grad gekühlt damit
eine formbare masse entsteht das kam so
ein bisschen vergleichen wie mit dem
temperieren von schokolade
und dann kann es auch schon direkt ans
portionieren gehen das noch sehr heiße
flüssige glas fällt als tropfen in die
form und diese heiße rote glas tropfen
stellt auch das passe wachtel oder
das glas kann nun entweder geblasen
gepresst oder gesponnen werden
wir stellen wir jetzt gerade borgia im
ofen formen aus borosilikatglas her
hier wird das glas gepresst um die
gewünschte form zu erhalten
nach dem pressen haben die formen aber
noch unebenheiten die durch eine weitere
fahrt und durch starke hitze ebenerdig
gemacht werden
das konnten wir uns auch im detail
anschauen
aber wir mussten unsere augen vor den
heißen flammen schützen
ein arbeiter prüft dann auch direkt ob
die maschinen korrekt laufen und das
glas die richtige form behält
falls nicht kann er die maschine einfach
anders einstellen um das problem dann
direkt zu beheben
nachdem die offenen formen dann
abgekühlt sind werden sie ein letztes
mal kontrolliert und fehlerhafte ware
wird dann eben noch aussortiert die
qualitätskontrolle findet nicht nur bei
born formen statt sondern auch bei allen
anderen glasprodukten von tasche machte
mitarbeiter aber auch maschinen
kontrollieren die ware damit der kunde
ein perfektes produkt am ende auf seinem
tisch oder in seinem wohnzimmer stehen
hat außerdem wird im labor die
allgemeine robustheit der verschiedenen
produkte getestet um sie eben auch stets
zu verbessern und fehler auszuschließen
um eine einwandfreie qualität zu
gewährleisten gibt stoß schlag oder auch
kaltes und auch die glas stärke wird
immer wieder kontrolliert
jetzt waren wir bei der
qualitätskontrolle die mit welcher sind
einwandfrei das silikat glas ist
wirklich super alles perfekt bestanden
hitze fest eure beständig bruchsicher
und jetzt kommen die hier auf dem
förderband denn ihr seht schon ein
messbecher ist erst dann ein herzlicher
wenn natürlich auch eine mess skala
drauf ist hier werde druck drauf
gedruckt und zwar hier mit drei farben
das heißt wir haben einmal das silly
logo in magenta das porsche logo in rot
und wer meine schrift in schwarz und das
ist wirklich einmalig und man musste
hier auch zwei arbeitsschritte noch mal
zusätzlich dazu machen um den drei
public hinzubekommen
ich glaube wir müssen schneller arbeiten
[Musik]
und hier kommen dann die wunderschönen
messbecher von wasserwacht und sally
heraus alles schön bedruckt mit dem drei
farbigen druck was wirklich einzigartig
auf der welt da kommen sie dann über das
förderband hin zur verpackung station
sagen wird gleich am nächsten kam
[Musik]
also wenn wir schon davon verpacken dann
natürlich auch selber würde ich sagen
[Musik]
annike krahn
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt aber wieder zu hause und haben
alles mitgebracht
er wird jetzt auch so eine
glasproduktion ist ziemlich aufwändig
sehr schweißtreibend für als ich muss
sagen wir waren ja dort war auch super
interessant aber jeden tag in der heißen
fabrik zu arbeiten das ist schon
wahnsinn also eine belastung sein körper
ja und kälte spruch schaffte vater ist
ein vater klar erkennen dass der stimmt
hier wirklich und es war wirklich also
eine krasse aktion richtig heiß da drin
also im knochen job ein echter hammer
aber ihr seht auch das pascha brachte
wirklich ein tal in nur innovatives und
auch sagt zukunftsorientiertes
unternehmen ist gerade wenn ich jetzt
bedenke wie blog zum beispiel eben das
glas was speziell beschichtet also
antibakteriell genau ohne gerade drauf
jetzt zur pandemie zeiten eben keine
bakterien oder viren weiterzugeben also
da denken die ja schon mit wurde das
glas was zu 100 prozent recycelt ich
aber trotzdem das noch durchschauen
kundin das wusste ich nicht dass man
wirklich das ist das 100 prozent
recyceln das glas eigentlich nicht
durchsichtig mensch ja und das macht mir
ich muss ich sagen mega stolz dass
tasche machte eben einer der größten
hersteller der welt uns als partner auch
gewählt hat ja und wir mit ihnen
arbeiten dürfen oder sogar ja und wir
sogar schon einzelne dieser kooperations
produkte sowohl haben also wenn man
wirklich zusammen diesen glas sehen
beide punkte aus borosilikatglas den
haben jetzt auch schon weil viele
gefragt
in einem liter mit einem liter volumen
hergestellt und werden das jetzt
gratulieren kommen lassen erst so ab
märz gesagt haben viele bräuche wünsch
also in ein meter und diese kleinen
messbecher ja weil für kleinstmengen hat
auch die kleinen messbecher mega
praktisch sind aber die jetzt auch noch
mit entwickelt und die werden jetzt auch
demnächst kommen also wirklich top
qualität topware und einfach auch ein
top unternehmen
was wird da versucht haben wir haben uns
jetzt gedacht machen wir ein schönes
gewinnspiele und paket für euch und zwar
würden wir euch diese dieses 2 sz der
borgia ofen formen geben und da ist auch
das besondere dass die wirklich einen
schönen rechten winkel haben denn
normalerweise sind auflaufformen auf
es gab immer anderen herstellern immer
nicht eckig sondern wächst so abgerundet
weil es eben von vom pressvorgang nicht
geht aber borgia bzw passiva hatte super
hingekriegt dann gibt es den borussia
liegt messbecher dazu und sogar noch die
gläser genau da einfach beide dürfen sie
ist auch nie machen weil ich gerne
machen aber sie sind hier so aus murat
und zum gläser genau und das gibt's ja
alles noch nicht das gibt es bald von
daher kann man das nicht mit verlosen
leider da müsst ihr euch leider noch ein
bisschen gedulden und die frage lautet
ich würde sagen genau was ist die
besonderheit von borosilikatglas uns
gerne in die kommentare und ich meine
wir können es einfach fünfmal verloren
ja also fünfmal verlosen das heißt wir
werden es dann zweimal auf facebook und
drei mal auf youtube oder immer und
sechs mal wenn man zwei facebook zwar
instagram zwei youtube genau dann ist es
aus genauer die frage und wird eine
coole geschichte und wir freuen uns auf
weitere dinge in unter shop gibt es
übrigens schon einiges von passage und
das heißt gläser auflaufform und
eindruck was dann schaut gerne mal
wirklich vorbei und schaue doch gerne
mal in eure schränke oder da wo er eben
seit und schreibt uns mal was er denn
wohl fürs foto gehabt dass er seinen weg
gehabt also viel spaß beim mit dem
gewinnspiel viel erfolg und vielen
vielen dank fürs zuschauen der
vielleicht eine wunderschöne das auch
wirklich was ganz immer was neues zu
lernen genauso wie ihr ihr habt gesehen
wie so was keiner wusste wie sie
hergestellt wird
was machen wir es nächstes jahr sehen
wir sind offen für alles fußball ist
dann ja liebe grüße übrigens in die
türkei
ich bin zu holen
das macht
[Musik]
the work sein
eine cataleya collection dieses nur für
katar leer gemacht
denn sarah hat wie ihr wisst die
schönste katze der welt die hier einfach
will
[Musik]
das video kann sich nun um ein paar
stunden vollgas keine videos einfügen